all right here is the setup I have a
rifle mounted vertically and we're going
to shoot a bullet into this block right
into the middle of it so obviously the
block is going to go flying into the air
we're going to do this again
and instead of firing the bullet right
into the middle of the block we're going
to shoot it off to one side and I want
you to make a prediction will that
spinning block when we hit it to one
side will it go the same height as this
first block will it go
not as high or will it go higher okay so
versus being shot in the middle when you
shoot on the side is the question right
yeah how high will it go in comparison
it depends on if the bullet stays in the
block I'm assuming it does it does stay
in the block yes like you want to you
they you same height I'm surely basing
it on just like an instinct that I have
I feel like I'm being tricked I just
feel like you're trying to trick us and
that it's gonna do something that we
can't predict I thought maybe something
is not as high so I'm gonna say hi ha ha
I'll say hi but it's gonna like find if
they're actually shopping so you have
angular momentum we L yeah and he had
translational momentum which is P yeah
when you hit in the middle of the block
the block doesn't really spin and also
it just goes up to certain height but
when you hit it on the side block it's
going to be spinning Siskin have
imparted some kinetic energy so there
won't be as much potential energy and so
the total energy the system basically
has to say constant and the kinetic plus
potential which would be the height it
goes to will have to be constant so if
it's fitting it has kinetic energy it
can't go as high that's my prediction
so my prediction is it will go up not as
high but it'll spin more if it's hit to
the side am I wrong
I want you to think which do you think
is the most reasonable and then click
one of the annotations above all right
are you ready make your prediction in
three two one
you